Ventura County Sheriff Jeff Dean is with
us good morning sheriff
good morning we're very sorry for your
loss particularly sheriff ron Heelys
what can you tell us about your friend
ron was a 50 year old 29 year veteran in
the Sheriff's Office he was my gym buddy
we worked out together he was a father a
husband and he died tonight going in to
try to save others and made the ultimate
sacrifice
sheriff you describe the training after
the shooting at Columbine that everyone
including sergeant Heelys engaged in
what was that training and to respond to
an active shooter situation well it was
kind of a change in law enforcement
philosophy instead of waiting and
surrounding and bringing a SWAT team
once our officers arrived on scene with
one or two or three officers and they
believe there may be an active threat
inside they go in and try to neutralize
the threat what can you tell us about
the scene that you saw when you arrived
it was a horrific scene
the when the officers went in the
suspect was already dead but it was a
horrific there were 11 victims inside
bless the suspect and then in addition
my sergeant was killed trying to make
entry I know that sergeant Heelys
entered alone do you believe that he
saved so many more lives well he was
actually in the accompaniment of a
higher patrol officer had shown up and
they went in together and there's no
doubt that him going in the high patrol
officer going in helped neutralize
whatever threat was going on why was
this bar or individuals in the bar
targeted we have absolutely no idea
we're early on to this investigation
it's a Thousand Oaks a very low crime
very nice area it's a nightclub that
holds a variety of events pretty low-key
type nightclub and we're not sure the
numbers probably over 100 people were in
there so we have no idea what the motive
was of the suspect because we're have
yet to identify them and we know that it
is Ventura County's largest country
dance hall and music venue witnesses
there said that they did not see any
armed security they only saw what looked
like perhaps bouncers do you know if
there were any armed security at the
venue I don't know for sure but
historically they have not had armed
security at this location in the past
can you tell us anything about this
particular night we know that it was
open to college kids it was a college
night for kids can you tell us what
normally goes on in this particular
night at the club
you know I couldn't tell you what goes
on this particular night but they have
different events every night they have
comedy shows they have line dancing it's
not what you consider a wild nightclub
it's a pretty comfortable venue for
young people to come and dance and enjoy
themselves I also heard you say earlier
that it's hard to make sense of the
senseless those words really resonate
with a lot of people this particular
shooting is both personal and
professional for you and I'm wondering
how you're processing it what you're
doing well you know it's the loss of
human life is always so sad and when I
wanted to look at the scene I knew there
were mothers and fathers and brothers
and sisters of those victims that were
in there and it's certainly very
personal that someone who I've worked
with for 29 years also lost his life
tonight sergeant we we know that and
sheriff we know that tomorrow is your
last day and the job there after 41
years and the job and we're just so
sorry that this is the eve of your final
day there we appreciate you joining us
and then thank you so much